Armelle c'est un sommet en temps de
guerre 500 jours après le début de
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine
oui c'est un sommet en temps de guerre
et ce surtout un soumet dans un pays un
peu particulier la littiganie qui est un
état balte et sur lequel on voit
beaucoup d'affiches qui proposent
justement à ce que l'Ukraine entre dans
l'OTAN un pays basque qui soutient donc
son pays voisin mais à un pays qui a
aussi une histoire qui s'inscrit
particulièrement dans le contexte
régional on est ici dans un pays qui du
12e au 15e siècle était un royaume qui
allait de la mer Baltique jusqu'à la mer
Noire un royaume très grand et un
royaume qui a un moment donné a été en
quelque sorte un peu rattrapé par les
Polonais qui pendant 200 ans l'ont donc
privé de son histoire et puis ensuite il
a été rattrapé par l'Empire russe qui
l'a croqué jusqu'à ce que il serait
récupère son indépendance rapidement
puisque ensuite c'est du RSS qui de
nouveau langue globé et il a récupéré
son indépendance en 1991 pourquoi je je
vous raconte tout ça parce que vous êtes
pile sur ce qui est en train de se
passer un pays qui a eu son indépendance
comme l'Ukraine en 1991 qui connaît le
joue d'avoir eu l'empire soviétique
au-dessus de lui et donc qui est capable
d'épauler l'Ukraine mais qui en même
temps c'est très bien que les alliances
sont de circonstances et que dans le
temps long que ce soit les Polonais que
ce soit les Russes il faut savoir
travailler avec eux mais il faut savoir
aussi sans méfier et aujourd'hui à
l'OTAN et bien l'actualité c'est pour
l'instant de parler d'aider l'Ukraine
vient de promettre un message clair et
positif injustement pour l'Ukraine que
peut bien nous obtenir vos lot-dix qui
est attendu on a ni la date ni l'heure
parce qu'il s'agit des questions de
sécurité on est ici sur un sommet des
chefs d'État habituellement on a
l'habitude d'avoir une très grande
sécurité surtout à partir du moment
donné où le président américain se
déplace ici ce qui nous a frappé quand
on est arrivé qu'on a atterri avec
l'équipe c'est qu'on a vu que tout le
long du tarmac et bien il y avait des
missiles patriotes qui étaient là et qui
était effectivement là pour protéger en
cas d'attaque c'est dans ce contexte que
l'on est le président zeniens ski vient
chercher de l'armement encore un peu
plus d'armement et ce qu'on entend
surtout c'est une déclaration de
soltenberg qui a reconnu effectivement
que la contre-offensive ukrainienne
rencontrait de gros problèmes de gros
problèmes en langage diplomatique
reconnu dans une enceinte comme celle de
l'OTAN ça veut dire clairement
effectivement que les difficultés des
Ukrainiens que le nombre de morts sur le
combat ukrainien qui est toujours
inconnu ne sont plus que jamais sur la
table et que même si l'on n'en parle pas
officiellement même si on prend pas une
voix médiatique le choix effectivement
d'armer un peu plus du crâne montre
l'effectivement les difficultés dans
lequel sont aujourd'hui les ukrainiens
et on le lit effectivement ce choix
quand les États-Unis acceptent d'envoyer
des obus à soumission des obus
soumission ce sont des obus qui
n'impacte pas toujours et lorsque il se
disperse et bien ça reste dangereux pour
la population dangereuse pour la
population pour les futurs générations
c'est pour ça que c'est interdit par les
accords d'Oslo de 2008 pour protéger les
populations la France a ratifié par
exemple le Royaume-Uni aussi les
États-Unis ne l'ont pas fait ils parlent
justement de l'exporter vis-à-vis de
l'Ukraine et ça montre dans quelle
difficulté on se trouve aujourd'hui les
Allemands le président allemand a dit
qu'il ne fallait pas bloquer les
Ukrainiens mais clairement on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec une Ukraine
qui demande une adhésion à l'OTAN ce qui
va être compliqué puisque comme c'est un
pays en guerre statut avec l'article 5
normalement il ne peut pas rentrer et il
me demande effectivement d'aider
après 500 jours vous l'avez rappelé et
Elisabeth deguerre aider pour aller
justement vers un avenir merci beaucoup
Armelle